*Here we find a New Pokèmon trainer suddenly screaming in a somehow cute way*
(The sound of a thousand fists heading for that clock)
*Markimoo the new trainer in town gets dressed to go on a pokèmon adventure*
*Mark then shows off his dank booty for views*
*Some wonderful zipping Sounds*
*Puts on his new yellow gloves that match his team*
*Coolness level over 100,000,000!!!*
*markimoo is ready to catch some pokemans*
(Drops hat, like a doof)
*Mark begins his journey to be the very best that no-one ever was*
Guys?
Guys...?
No shelter from the storm...?
[Cheery singsong voice]
I
I have
[Cheery singsong voice]
I have no
I have no FRIENDS
Except Youtube...YouTube is always here Mark.
Always